I teach a course called religion and
sexuality which I had intended to be a
small seminar but has ended up being a
slightly larger course I teach every two
years and enrolls between 80 and 120
students and the first day I explain the
themes of the course essentially as a
series of way of encouragement that you
leave if you're uncomfortable with so I
say I think you should probably leave if
you really don't like religion I think
you should probably leave if you really
really don't like sex and third I think
you should leave if you're going to be
incredibly uncomfortable with ambiguity
and I do that both because it's a
shopping period class and I want
students to feel like they're getting
the class that they expect but also
because to me the entire point of the
course is to subvert the things that
they normally think about those
categories imagining that religions are
all awful orthodoxies that keep people
from their freedom and that sex is
always a source of freedom these are
things that I want them to think about
and come back to after reading a lot of
material on American religious history
and particularly the way religious
movements prescribed particular sexual
behavior but also the way that the
broader culture has in it various sexual
acts promoted talked about prescribed
that themselves have a kind of ritual
aspect when I was originally planning
the course and thinking of it as a
seminar I did a lot of research of
primary documents in American religion
where their explicit sexual
prescriptions and the person that I
first researched was a man named John
Humphrey Noyes who is most famous in the
broader culture for coining the term
free love but within the American
religious history is known as somebody
who was obsessed with the idea of
perfection that human beings could be
rid of sin and he was particularly
interested in the idea that he's sourced
in the New Testament where Jesus says
that in heaven there will be no marriage
and he decided that he believes really
essential practice for all human beings
would be a sort of notion of complex
marriage in which to speak kind of
abbreviated about very complicated
system we were all essentially married
to one another and I've always known
about John Humphrey Noyes
I'd always known about the United
perfectionist
that he led in upstate New York but I
had never understood that this
revelation occurred to him while he was
at Yale and that got me to thinking as I
was reading a lot of articles in The New
York Times and other paper is about Yale
graduates and what they were doing after
graduation and I started thinking for
all the amazing things that Yale
graduates do and they do so many amazing
things I would like to hear more of them
leading Brigades of new sexual
revolution and thinking through what
kind of lives we live in this present
culture as sexual beings and what really
excited me to discover this about noise
was to imagine teaching a course that
got students to think of themselves as
leaders not only of politics and
economics but also of sexual
consciousness in the course we have a
couple different kinds of assignments
the first one this semester that the
students are actually writing right now
is they have to write a response to
young man's memoir and polemic young
recent graduate of Yale who wrote a book
called sexy God at Yale where he wrote a
pretty sharp critique of what he felt
was a kind of excessive sexual culture
among the undergraduates here and I'm
kind of failure of intellectual and
moral discipline towards their sexual
selves and right now the students are
writing they've read some of hardens
book and I've invited them to write a
letter to the editor about this book not
literally to send it off unless they so
choose but to try to create an argument
about how they think about their sexual
culture at Yale relative to hardness
readings other assignments in the class
include asking them to write a speech
for Michelle Obama using the writings of
Michelle Foucault to think through about
the nature of the body and how important
the body is for the National politic
this is in response to Michelle Obama's
let's move campaign they're also going
to be asked to write a nomination for a
text to be used in the course something
from popular culture or from American
religious history where they find a
religious group and research their
prescriptions for sexual action all of
these assignments show that my intention
is to try to draw in students who are
interested in getting an introduction to
the humanities we talk a lot in the
course about basic acts of argumentation
and close reading but also to try to
pull from as many disciplines as
Cybil and to not imagine that they are
coming in and must know anything in
advance of the course about the history
of sexuality about the history of
America or about the history of gender
what I want them to do is to come in and
think that they themselves have
resources to call upon their own
experiences and perceptions and while I
discourage first-person talk in class
what I encourage is using all that
first-person passionate about what
they've perceived in their worlds to
come and bear on these texts in the
class I've had everything from football
players to powerful queer activists
there's a wide array and I think that
they're brought to the course precisely
because the course does not take any
position other than you yourself have
something to say about the discomfort
you have about the sexual culture you
occupy and I found in teaching it here
that over and over again students come
to understand and be able to name what
they find so structuring and limiting
about American sexual culture and I hope
they then lead new rebellions about ways
we could live within it
as an LGBT person myself I'm acutely
acutely sensitive to the way that issues
of sexual concern sexual crisis sexual
politics often seem in the public sphere
to be dominated by LGBT people that the
question of sexual suffering or sexual
confusion seems to be largely a desire
to manage the LGBT population I've tried
to design this course in a way that
emphasizes its inclusivity insofar as I
want to have people in the room who come
in imagining themselves to be any number
of sexual identities and what I like
them to come out as is not the bunked of
those identities but to imagine that the
boundaries of those conceptions have
been designed by someone else and that
what we have to try to do is to bring
our own consciousness to bear upon our
experiences and to do that with as much
care and concern for the history that
brings us to this present one of my
great excitements about the course is
when I have a student come into my
office who says that they came because
they're a religious Studies major and
that this fill the requirements or that
they just thought it would be a fun way
to fill up kind of introductory
humanities credit and that they say that
over the course the class that they came
to realize how
much they see in the media about LGBT
people about women's rights are really
caricatures and caricatures invented to
propound a certain form of ideal
sexuality they made them realize how
much of their life was itself a kind of
assignment an assignment to be a kind of
person that they didn't feel themselves
to be and even as they may go on to
study something far afield from the
study of religion and sexuality they
will continue to hold that inside
themselves as something that guides them
not only as scholars or as professionals
but also as human beings trying to
fulfill their greatest purpose